Mortal Kombat 11 has taken the [ __ ] to
the next level by creating a fully
realized version of Shang soon's island
to explore in a mini third-person
adventure mode much of the island is
locked off by puzzles and certain key
items you'll need to find in this video
we're going to show you where to find
the major key items that you'll need to
explore the majority of the island as
well as tips on how to obtain the
trickier items picking up Shao Kahn's
hammer at the beginning is going to give
you access to most of the island surface
but eventually you'll start encountering
locked doors with nowhere else to go
your next step is to enter the islands
underground caves which is through this
door that requires mataró as horn when
you first find the store a cutscene
plays where a meteorite crashes down
break the meteorite with your hammer to
receive the gem of the living head back
to the courtyard and break down this
wall on the east side to access an area
with a gong in the middle go use the gem
of the living on this door this will
lead to a shortcut back to the main
entrance and passes gate is the Horn of
motaro using the horn on the door opens
up the entire underground which is a lot
to explore and uncover the next key item
you'll want to find is located here off
of Goro's dining hall take this elevator
and you'll end up at the bottom of the
pit and find our Mack
taking his amulet lets you manipulate
Souls mean you now have the ability to
open these green soul containers with
the amulet you can also access new areas
by spending souls for example you can
fix the bridge path but that's also
gonna cost you a pretty penny of 2000
Souls so get to saving head back to
girls throne room and take the path on
the right of girls corpse that will lead
you south to the armory on the far side
of the wall is the spear of hanzo
hasashi use the spear to break objects
such as lanterns to open doors and
unlock pathways it can also be used to
pull hanging corpses towards you which
will get you hearts head back to Goro's
throne room one last time and take the
path east go past the treasure chamber
into the jails and take a left to
discover the fate of the blind swordsman
kenchi using kench's blindfold lets you
view the spirit realm you'll find hidden
treasures and new walls that can be
broken with Shao Kahn's hammer just be
wary of evil spirits with all these
items you can explore the majority of
Shang Tsung's Island however there are
still plenty of locked doors and
contraptions that need additional key
items
unfortunately these won't be as easy to
get you'll find them in all sorts of
places somewhere in chess but in our
experience these are random so we can't
really tell you where to look we've also
had luck earning items in the Tower of
time and by completing challenges if
spending hours trying to unlock all the
finishers is too much for you and you
just want to see them then check out our
compilation videos of fatalities
brutalities and finishing blows